apologies sir uh let's just cross over
to
the president and listen to what he has
to say on afghanistan september
and we're on track to meet that target
excuse me
our military mission after mission
afghanistan will conclude
on august 31st the drawdown is
proceeding in a secure and orderly way
prioritizing the safety of our troops as
they depart
our military commanders advised me that
once i made the decision to end the war
we needed to move swiftly to conduct the
main elements of the drawdown
and in this context speed is safety
and thanks to the way in which we have
managed our withdrawal
no one no one us forces or any forces
have
have been lost conducting our drawdown
differently would have certainly come
with a
increased risk of safety to our
personnel
to me those risks were unacceptable
and there was never any doubt that our
military performed this
task efficiently and with the highest
level of professionalism
that's what they do and the same is true
of our nato allies and partners who have
supported
we are supporting and supporting us as
well as they conclude their retrograde
i want to be clear the us military
mission afghanistan
continues through the end of august we
remain
we retain personnel and capacities in
the country
and we maintain some authority to should
be the same authority
under which we've been operating for
some time
as i said in april the united states did
what we want to do
in afghanistan to get the terrorists to
attack us on 9 11
and deliver justice to osama bin laden
and to degrade the terrorist threat to
keep afghanistan from becoming a base
from which attacks could be continued
against the united states
we achieved those objectives that's why
we went
we did not go to afghanistan to nation
build
and it's the right and the
responsibility of afghan people alone to
decide their future
and how they want to run their country
together
with our nato allies and partners we
have trained and equipped
over three nearly 300 000
current serving members of the military
the afghan not security force
and many beyond that who are no longer
serving
add to that hundreds of thousands more
afghan national defense and security
forces
trained over the last two decades we
provided our afghan partners with all
the tools let me
emphasize all the tools training
equipment
of any modern military we provided
advanced weaponry
and we're going to continue to provide
funding and equipment
and will ensure they have the capacity
to maintain their air force
but most critically as i stressed in my
meeting just two weeks ago with
president ghani
and chairman abdullah afghan leaders
have to come together and drive toward a
future
that the afghan people want and they
deserve
in our meeting i also assured ghani that
u.s support
for the people of afghanistan will
endure
we will continue to provide civilian and
humanitarian assistance
including speaking out for the rights of
women and girls
i intend to maintain our diplomatic
presence in afghanistan and we are
coordinating closely
with our international partners in order
to continue to secure the international
airport
and we're going to engage in a
determined diplomacy
to pursue peace and a peace agreement
that will end this senseless violence
i've asked secretary of state lincoln
and our special representative
for afghanistan reconciliation to work
vigorously
with the parties in afghanistan as well
as the regional and international
stakeholders to support
a negotiated solution to be clear
to be clear countries in the region have
an essential role to play in supporting
a peaceful settlement we'll work with
them
and they should help step up their
efforts as well
we're going to continue to work for the
release of detained americans including
uh mark
ferrigs i want to pronounce the name
correctly i miss
i misspoke so that he can return to his
family safely
we're also going to continue to make
sure that we take on the
afghan nationals who work side by side
with u.s forces including interpreters
and translators
since we're no longer going to have
military there after this we're not
going to need them and they
have no jobs we're also going to be
vital to our efforts
so they and they've been very vital and
so their families are not exposed to
danger as well
we've already dramatically accelerated
the procedure
uh time for special immigrant visas to
bring them to the united states
since i was inaugurated on january 20th
we've already approved 2
500 special immigrant visas to come to
the united states
up to now fewer than half have exercised
their right to do that
half have gotten on aircraft income
commercial flights income
and other halfs believe they want to
stay at least thus far
working closely with congress to change
the authorization legislation
so that we can streamline the process of
approving those visas
and those who have stood up for the
operation to physically relocate
thousands of afghans and their families
before the u.s military mission
concludes
so that if they choose they can wait
safely
outside of afghanistan while their u.s
visas are being processed
the operation has identified u.s
facilities outside
the continent of the united states as
well as in third countries
to host our afghan allies if they choose
they so choose
and this uh starting this month we're
going to begin to re
relocate we're going to begin relocation
flights
for afghanistan siv applicants uh and
their families who choose to leave
we have a point person in the white
house and at the state department-led
task force
coordinating all these efforts but our
message
to those women and men is clear
there is a home for you in the united
states if you so choose
and we will stand with you just as you
stood with us
when i made the decision to end the us
military involvement in afghanistan
i judged that it was not in the national
interest of united states america
to continue fighting this war
indefinitely
i made the decision with clear eyes and
i'm briefed daily on the battlefield
updates
but for those who have argued that we
should stay just six more months
or just one more year i asked them to
consider the lessons
of recent history in 2011
the nato allies and partners agreed that
we would end our combat mission
in 2014. in 2014 some argued one more
year
so we kept fighting we kept taking
casualties
in 2015 the same and on and on
nearly 20 years of experience has shown
us that the current security situation
only confirms
that just one more year of fighting in
afghanistan is not a solution
but a recipe for being there
indefinitely
it's up to the afghans to make the
decision about the future of their
country
others are more direct their argument is
that we should stay with the afghan
and afghanistan indefinitely in doing so
they
point to the fact that we we have not
taken losses in this last year
so they claim that the cost of just
maintaining the status quo is minimal
but that ignores the reality and the
facts that already presented on the
ground in afghanistan when i took office
the taliban was at his strongest
military
is at its strongest militarily since
2001.
the number of u.s forces in afghanistan
had been reduced to a bare minimum
and the united states and last
administration made an agreement that
they
to with the taliban and remove all our
forces by may one
of this past of this year that's what i
inherited
that agreement was the reason the
taliban had ceased major attacks against
u.s forces
if in april i'd instead announce that
the united states was going to
back going back on that agreement made
by the last administration
the united states and allied forces will
remain in afghanistan for
the foreseeable future the taliban would
have again begun to target our forces
the status quo was not an option stain
would have met u.s troops taking
casualties
american men and women back in the
middle of a civil war
and we would run the risk of having to
send more troops back into afghanistan
to defend our remaining troops
once that agreement of the taliban had
been made staying with a bare minimum
force
was no longer possible so let me ask
those who
want us to stay how many more
how many thousands more americans
daughters and sons
are you willing to risk how long would
you have them stay
already we have members of our military
whose parents fought in afghanistan 20
years ago
would you send their children and their
grandchildren as well
would you send your own son or daughter
after 20 years a trillion dollars spent
training and equipping
hundreds of thousands of afghan national
security and defense forces
2 448 americans
killed 20 722 more wounded
and untold thousands coming home with
unseen trauma to their mental health
i will not send another generation of
americans to war in afghanistan
with no reasonable expectation of
achieving a different outcome
the united states cannot afford to
remain tethered to policies
creating a response to the world as it
was 20
years ago we need to meet the threats
where they are
today today the terrorist threat has
metastasized beyond afghanistan
so we are repositioning our resources
and adapting our counterterrorism
posture
to meet the threats where they are now
significantly higher in south asia the
middle east and africa
but make no mistake our military and
intelligence leaders are
confident they have the capabilities to
protect the homeland
and our interests from any resurgent
terrorist challenge
emerging or emanating from afghanistan
we are developing a counter terrorism
over the horizon capability
that will allow us to keep our eyes
firmly fixed
and any direct threats to the united
states and the region and act quickly
and decisively if needed
we also need to focus on shoring up
america's core strengths
to meet the the strategic competition
with china and other nations that is
really going to determine determine our
future
we have to defeat covet 19 at home and
around the world
make sure we're better prepared for the
next pandemic or biological threat
we need to establish international norms
for cyberspace
and the use of emergency emerging
technologies
we need to take concerted action to
fight existential threats of
climate change and we will be more
formidable to our adversaries and
competitors over the long run
if we fight the battles of the next 20
years
not the last 20 years finally
i want to recognize the incredible
sacrifice and dedication
that the u.s military and civilian
personnel serving alongside our allies
and partners
have made over the last two decades in
afghanistan
i want to honor the significance of what
they've accomplished
and the great personal risk they
encountered
an incredible cost to their families
pursuing the terrorist threat
to some of the most unforgiving terrain
on the planet i've been almost
throughout that entire country
ensuring there hasn't been another
attack on the homeland from afghanistan
for the last 20 years taking out bin
laden
i want to thank you all for your service
and the dedication to the mission so
many of you have
given and to the sacrifices that you and
your families have made
over the long course of this war
we'll never forget those who gave the
last full measure of devotion for their
country in afghanistan
nor are those whose lives have been
immeasurably altered by wounds sustained
in the service of the country we're
ending
america's longest war
but we'll always always honor the
bravery of the american patriots who
served it
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you mr president mr president
is a taliban takeover of afghanistan now
inevitable
no it is not why
because you have the afghan troops have
300
000 well-equipped as well as quipped as
any army
in the world and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable
[Applause]
you trust the taliban mr president you
trust the television
is that a serious question it's
absolutely a serious question you trust
the taliban
no i do not country to the taliban no i
do not trust
the
mr president taliban you amplify that
question please will you amplify your
answer please why you don't trust it
it's a silly question do i trust the
taliban no
but i trust the capacity of the afghan
military
who is better trained better equipped
and more re
more competent in terms of conducting
war yes ma'am
thank you mr president given the amount
of money that has been spent and the
number of lives that have been lost in
your view with making this decision
were the last 20 years worth it
you know my record i can tell by the way
you asked the question
i opposed permanently
having american forces in afghanistan
i argued from the beginning as you may
recall
it came to light after
the administration was over last in
our administration no nation has ever
unified afghanistan
no nation empires have gone there
and not done it the
focus we had and i strongly support it
and you may remember i
physically went to afghanistan
i was up in that pass where osama bin
laden
was allegedly escaped or out of
harm's way we went
for two reasons one
to
bring osama bin laden
to the gates of hell as i said at the
time
the second reason was to eliminate
al-qaeda's capacity to deal with more
attacks in the united states from that
territory
we accomplished both of those objectives
period that's what i believe from the
beginning
why we should be and why we should have
gone to
afghanistan that job had been
over for some time and that's why i
believe
that this is the right decision and
quite frankly overdue
mr president thank you very much your
own intelligence community has assessed
that the afghan government will
likely collapse that's not true is it
can you please clarify what they have
told you about
whether that will happen or not that is
not true
they did not they didn't did not reach
that conclusion
what is the level of confidence that
they have that it will not collapse
the afghan government
and leadership has to come together they
clearly have the capacity to sustain
the government in place the question is
will they generate the kind of cohesion
to do it
it's not a question of whether they have
the capacity they have the capacity
they have the forces they have the
equipment
the question is will they do and i want
to make clear what i made clear to gani
that we are not going to walk away and
not sustain their ability to maintain
that force
we are we're going to also work to make
sure we help them in terms of
everything from food necessities and
other things in in
in the region but but
there is not a conclusion that in fact
they cannot
defeat the taliban i believe the only
way there's going to be this is not
joe biden not the intelligence community
the only way there's ultimately going to
be peace and security in afghanistan
is that they work out a modus of vendai
with the taliban
and they make a judgment as to how they
can make peace
and the likelihood there's going to be
one unified government in afghanistan
controlling the whole country is highly
unlikely
but we have talked to your own top
general in afghanistan general scott
miller he told abc news
the conditions are so concerning at this
point that it could result
in a civil war so if kabul falls to the
taliban what will the united states do
about it
look
you've said two things one that if
it could result in a civil war that's
different than the taliban succeeding
number one number two the question of
what will be done
is going to be implicated it can
implicate the entire region as well
there's a number of countries have a
grave concern about what's going to
happen
in afghanistan relative to their
security
the question is how much of a threat
to the united states of america and to
our allies
is whatever results in terms of a
government or an agreement
that's when that judgment will be made
mr president some some vietnamese
veterans see
echoes of their experience in this
withdrawal in afghanistan do you see any
parallels between
this withdrawal and what happened in
vietnam with some people feeling
whatsoever zero what you had is you had
entire brigades breaking through the
gates
of our embassy six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a embassy in the of the united states
from afghanistan it is not at all
comfortable
hang on a second mr president how
serious was the corruption
among the afghanistan government to this
mission failing there
well first of all the mission hasn't
failed yet
there is uh in afghanistan
and all parties there's been corruption
the question is can there be an
agreement on unity or purpose
what is the objective for example it
started off there were going to be
negotiations
between the taliban and the afghan
national security forces
and the afghan government that
that didn't come to
didn't come to fruition so the question
now is
where do they go from here that the jury
is still out
but the likelihood there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything
and owning the whole country is highly
unlikely yes ma'am
will the united states be responsible
for the loss of
afghan civilian lives that could happen
after a military exit
no no no it's up to the people of
afghanistan
to decide on what government they want
not us to impose the government on them
no country's ever been able to do that
keep in mind as a student of history as
i'm sure you are
never has afghanistan been a united
country
not in all of its history not in all of
its history
if this isn't a mission accomplished
moment what is it
no there's no mission accomplished
the mission was accomplished in that we
get a scott osama bin laden
and terrorism is not emanating from that
part of the world
[Music]
as you just said in your remarks are you
satisfied with the timeline of
relocating
afghan nationals is it happening quickly
enough to your satisfaction
if it may not happen until next month at
the end much of this already happened
there's already been people about a
thousand people have gotten on aircraft
and come on
come to the united states already on
commercial aircraft so as i said there's
over 2500 people that
as from january to now have have gotten
the those visas and only half decided
that they
wanted to leave the point is that i
think the whole process
has to be speeded up period in terms of
being able to get these visas
why can't the u.s evacuate these afghan
translators
to the united states to await their visa
processing as
some immigrants of the southern border
doesn't allow that to happen
and that's why we're asking the congress
to consider changing the law
but in the meantime we can guarantee
their safety if they wish to leave by
taking the third countries
and or while the wait is taking place to
come to
uh um to and hopefully while they're
waiting there
to be able to bring them back to the
united states if that's what they choose
to do
good message for afghan women and future
because they have achievement
they are really concerned about their
achievement
they are very concerned with good reason
when i was in afghanistan
i've been there a number of times i
remember being in a school
outside and uh and by the way the
the schools in afghanistan are not
fundamentally unlike
schools on the west coast where they
have you know a
an area in the middle that is sort of
like
looks like a playground and single story
buildings
uh connected around it and i remember
saying to uh speaking to a group of
young women i guess they're roughly
found homeless they look like they'd be
14 15 years old and they're in school
there's a tiered classroom with single
light bulbs hanging from
the ceiling as i know you know and
i said you know the united states came
here
to make sure that we got this terrace
osama bin laden and
that terrorist didn't amass again to go
after our country
and then we're going to have to leave
and the young woman said you can't leave
you can't leave it was it was
heartbreaking you can't leave she said i
want to be a doctor
i want to be a doctor i want to be a
doctor if you leave
i'll never be able to be a doctor well
that's why we spent so much time and
money
training the afghan security forces
to do the work of defending that if
every work
well anyway so yes i'm aware
i'm going to take one more question
in russia today mr president i
thank you i i wanted to ask with the
benefit of hindsight
you've spoken to the fact that the
taliban are sort of at their militarily
strongest point
that you've seen in 20 years how do you
feel personally about that with the
benefit of hindsight and all of the
dollars and investments
and american troops that were sent there
relative to
the training and capacity of the ansf
and the trained the federal police
they're not even close
in terms of the capacity i was making
the point
the point was that here we were i was
the argument is well we could stay
because no one was dying
no americans are being shot so why leave
once the agreement was made by the last
administration we were going to leave by
may 1st
it was very clear that a taliban that
had always been a problem
was even a more sophisticated problem
than they were than before
not more sophisticated than the ansf
then government more than they were the
point being that
it would have increased the prospect
that they would have been able to take
more lives of americans if they decided
we weren't going to go after them that
was the point i was making
thank you all so very much